hello facebookers uh face
facebook facebook worms
it's me pete holmes here to answer some
of your pete holm show me pete questions
that you use the hashtag meatpeat for
those meatbeat questions carolyn
calderwood would like to know which do
you prefer blondes brunettes or redheads
if you meant what i prefer in a sex
person
i'm not gonna say that for fear of
ruining my chances with one of the other
two that you mentioned
because if i say online i love them
brunettes and then some brassy sassy
redhead comes up shaking in my face
tomorrow right before we seal the deal
she goes let me check my facebook
no thanks carolyn calderwood
stephanie akrie asks are you divorced
james lynch wants to know if you had a
statue of someone in your backyard who
would it be
james i live in an apartment and i don't
have a backyard but if i did i'd build a
statue of you
james lynch i've never even seen you
that way i'd have you over would go
outside and look at it be a surprise for
both of us
they really nailed it
especially your big old dick
josh jensen would like to know how many
brownies are too many brownies well josh
i think i know what you're setting me up
here for uh this is the fun-loving card
and i'm supposed to go there's no such
thing as too many brownies
but let's be honest there is such a
thing as too many brownies maybe you're
diabetic maybe you're shame eating in
your car parked outside of a bakery
that's long closed and you should be
home helping your daughter cynthia with
her homework but instead you're making
sweet face love to brownie brownie mush
in your car
occasionally catching shame glimpses in
your rear view mirror getting a little
reality check
maybe start up that car maybe throw out
the remaining four or five brownies and
help sin with that homework then help
yourself
to a helping of something other than
brownies
you